so like why smash what got you into that
oh like super smash bros yeah you
because you you're like what's the
matter
in general
everything philosopher's been working on
this for a while how did that get in uh
smash bros was because smash four came
out and i wanted to be better than my
friends no always the third one oh
it goes yeah ultimate
you make me so disappointed
it's the one for wii u and this is
literally called four it's called smash
4 wii u
smash 4 smash 4 wii u why can't you just
say which one it is why did you say
number he did he said smash 4. i'm
explaining why you're wrong i'm sorry i
don't know the chronological order of
all the smash games it's called smash 4
though it's not like it was called like
smash four fight fight fight smash wii u
just say smash wheels right now
he's a real snap creator clash two me
versus you
uh
i got into it because smash four for the
wii u in 3ds that came out in 2016 came
out and i uh and i was the worst in my
friend group
uh and i was always the worst of my
friend group and so i wanted to be
better than them because i went to
college and i was like i'll come back
and i'll beat their ass like an anime
yeah so i went through a training arc
and i watched a bunch of videos online
of j tales and that's where i found like
retro gaijin and i would watch his
streams to get better and i got a lot
better and i even showed up to like some
events uh and i came back and
i pummeled them just whooped their asses
which i found out it turns out it's not
that fun whatever i was gonna say yeah
when you're way better than your friends
they don't wanna play with you because
they keep losing and it's sad so the
gratification i had of being better was
replaced by sorrow of not being able to
play with them because they didn't want
to play with me anymore suffering from
success
this is just one punch man man yeah
right yeah
it was too easy yeah no opponents for me
uh well then i found out though there
was a competitive scene because when
what happens is you beat your friends
you're like i'm goaded i'm the customer
i'm god like i want to play someone
better and you go to all the locals and
you're like oh wait
i'm actually like level three yeah and
i'm all the way down here did you get
stomped the first local you went to
first local for smash 4 i did okay but i
watched the i don't know if you've heard
of this the smash documentary yeah yeah
yeah yeah have you guys seen it
four-hour one yeah yeah yeah so i
watched that and i was like i'm playing
the wrong game
and i switched to melee and then i was
like i was all the way down here i was
terrible because they have like decades
yeah yeah yeah work put into it and
people have trained for a long time and
and i found out that the the college i
went to there's a hundred man locals it
was like free to play no prize entry uh
and no money for you winning but they
just play for the fun of it right and uh
and a hundred people show up and and i
wanted to get better so i was trying to
go through a training arc so i did this
thing one time that i saw in the
documentary where i challenged a bunch
of guys who are in a clan to a money
match
yeah they were called uh they were
called [ __ ] lot
and that was their clan name and i
challenged each and every one of them to
a money match and they just ran a train
on me oh yeah just one by one dusting me
taking ten dollars from me until one guy
pulled out donkey kong which is like one
of the worst characters and he beat my
ass with donkey kong which is never
supposed to be jigglypuff and i was like
demoralized from it uh
but that's it it also made me addicted
so i just played like every day for like
three years from then right damn did you
ever get any good
i i i mean about it now i was like all
right i was
i beat like a couple notable people like
chillin dudes mario yeah
which is not his main character
and i got top eight at a charity
tournament once
yeah pretty good not bad
not bad uh but i was alright i i never i
switched pretty quickly to commentary
cause like wait i don't have to try and
i can make fart jokes and
you get more twitter followers you get
more stage time yeah that's cool oh damn
do you ever want to get like did you
ever want to pursue it further or get
even better or you just like nah i've
reached my ceiling do you ever have this
thing where you really want to be good
at something but then you think about
being good at it and you feel the
gratification of thinking about being
good
i did that
i i i thought about this
and it's like it's like a micro hit
but it is it is it is instant as opposed
to like the literal five years of work
you would need to put in to get the true
satisfaction
so you're getting that fake serotonin
yeah you're getting that real serotonin
micro dosing on happiness yeah
oh
every morning yeah
it's good it's like it's like if you
find a sick anime and you're like [ __ ]
this is the greatest anime and you want
to find something else like it but you
just never try to find something else
like it you're just like nah i'm good
i just re-watch one piece for like five
minutes yeah literally and i'll just
re-watch this in my mind and i'll be the
best in my mind except it never happened
right yeah but it's okay
in my mind i'm sick
so when did you start watching anime
well i applied for so i worked at apple
uh okay which i i was um they had a
college program and i would do tech
support which was my numbing because i
would talk to 60 year old people on how
to reset their iphone
and and i was good at it too i was like
top 10 at one point out of like 2000 in
the college program old people
yeah because like they would they would
they would they have every single metric
on her so it's like how long were you on
the call were they was it a successful
call did they give you a positive review
how quickly did you pick up a call after
hanging up that call because you
answered back in the queue like was your
downtime good and so they they tracked
all of this and like i had a six month
period where i was like
just going off trying to do really well
yeah uh but after two and a half years
it was like it was great for two and a
half years yeah oh my gosh
so i would watch anime on the side
and uh and i did it because um
oh this is so cringe i even hate talking
about this
all right
so i usually what happens is you go to
college in a different state or
somewhere else a different city then you
come back home for the summer yeah one
summer i was like no
sigma
i'm gonna stay in this town because i
have the dorm anyway yeah and i'm gonna
work on self-improvement okay and i made
a youtube channel called
self-improvement
and every day
i would i would work on fitness i would
work on learning a new language
and i would work on playing the piano
okay and by the end of the summer i
would like
have my level up moment yeah and i would
record myself
running at like 9 00 p.m in 95 degree
weather in phoenix arizona and then just
take a picture of myself shirtless like
fully relaxed and i just i imagined a
time lapse through all of this right and
i'd like practice a piano and i'd be
like ichi knee songs
and i uploaded like maybe two of these
right uh and i recorded intros on like
rooftop parking lots
uh again i'd never done youtube to this
point really right
and i got a call from my mom she's like
saw your youtube channel cause
unbeknownst to me it had been
cross-posted to my google plus account
which she had access to because she knew
my email yeah and this was like my one
viewer it was my mom
and i was mortified and i stopped it
that day she said she was like she was
like so you're doing some fitness stuff
huh
she didn't really get it she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing so your mom
stopped you from doing self-improvement
i was embarrassed and i didn't want my
my mom to be my only viewer watching me
running sure who knows what you could
have been right now you could have been
teaching a self-help
class and i'd probably be on the jet
program playing subpar piano running
around the streets of tokyo shirtless i
i'm happy with where it ended up
he reached in here man he like he's he's
mikey
it is ripped he's like the hunger joe
he's got it down he's playing russian
so how does it how does this
feedback to anime
well so then i quit that and instead
what i did is the rest of the summer
watch anime
literally
your mom find out you were doing
self-help so you were like i don't want
to do this
i'm going to become a weaver that's the
opposite of self-help is watching anime
yeah exactly that's what i did instead